there are four ways that chefs use to
control the viscosity their reductions
there's starch based thickener
there's making an emulsion by adding fat
or using modernist thickeners where
small amounts of material small amounts
of a polymer are added to increase the
viscosity by large amounts in all cases
what we're doing is adding something to
the fluid in the case of reduction we're
reducing the amount of liquid and what
remains our particles are non volatile
solids this increases the concentration
or the concentration of the solids in
the liquid in the case of starch we're
adding starch granules in the case of
fat or making an emulsion we're adding
drops of fat and the drops of fat behave
just like particles in the case of the
modernist thickeners we're adding
polymers and they also have the effect
of adding something to the fluid and
this is what increases the viscosity of
the fluid the simplest way to understand
this is to think of particles in the
fluid when the fluid flows the particles
also flow and they have to flow over one
another in order for the whole fluid to
flow the way they behave depends on the
concentration of the particles in the
fluid it depends on the volume of the
particles or the volume that the
particles occupy in the fluid this is
called volume fraction or the volume
fraction of particles in the fluid we
can calculate that easily we calculate
the volume of each of the particles and
we take the total number of particles
times their individual volume and divide
that by the total volume of the fluid
when there are very few particles will
move fluid or their volume fractions
very low then they have almost no effect
at all when the fluid flows the
particles just flow with the fluid
however when the volume fraction of the
particles increases then they become
crowded it's more difficult for the
particles to flow over one another and
they collide with each other they move
on top of each other they take much more
volume and the flow is restricted
it in this case the particles really
impact the flow of the fluid and
increase the viscosity of the fluid
however for that to happen the volume
fraction of particles has to be quite
high it has to be sufficiently high that
they can't easily flow over one another
this doesn't happen unless the volume
fraction of the particles gets to be of
the order of 50% or half the volume of
the fluid is occupied by the particles
when the volume fraction is so high then
the particles can't easily flow over one
another now we can understand in a very
simple way
why starch is so effective at increasing
the viscosity first the starch granules
expand they absorb water and they get
larger as we show in this little cartoon
the volume gets larger and so the volume
fraction the effective volume fraction
of the starch granules increases and
while you may start out with only 15%
volume fraction when they've expanded
then they can occupy a much larger
volume fraction the second way that
starch can increase the viscosity of the
fluid is a granules stick together in
that case they form these more tenuous
structures as we show here the volume of
these tenyo structures is the volume of
the structures themselves plus all the
water that they enclose as shown by this
circle and that's how you can greatly
increase the viscosity of fluid even if
you don't have essentially 50% of the
volume you have 50% of the volume
fraction of particles because the
particles occupy a much larger effective
volume the last way to increase the
viscosity is to add these modernist
thickeners what they are are large
molecules or polymers and in that case
only a very very small amount of
material can lead to a large increase in
the viscosity the way these work is
actually very similar to way the
particles work except that polymers have
a unique feature that they can occupy a
huge
vol with very little mass to understand
that let's understand the way a polymer
actually behaves a polymer is a very
long but very flexible molecule and is
made up of many many monomers and for a
polymer because it's so flexible
the bond between each of the monomers
can bend in any direction it can bend
either way it can bend one way or the
other way and it does that with equal
probability this has very much the
appearance of a random walk here's an
image of a random walk of an iron it can
go in any direction it goes randomly in
all different directions this random
walk is exactly what describes the
behavior of polymer and in fact we can
lay the polymer shape directly on to
this random walk so the same way we
describe the random walk that describes
a diffusion of ions through a fluid
that's the way we describe the shape of
a large polymer molecule what this means
is that the polymer molecule actually
takes up a huge amount of volume for a
very small amount of mass yet because
the polymer spread and filled the water
with this polymer it can increase its
viscosity by a very large amount because
the polymers occupy so little actual
volume of the fluid they can entangle
they can come together and intertwine
among each other that means the
effective volume of the polymers is
actually much greater than 1 and that
viscosity is even larger remember that
the polymers have to get out of the way
of one another in order for the fluid to
flow now they have to disentangle for
them to get out of each other's way
that's called rotation and that's a very
very slow process you can think of it
like a bowl of spaghetti if you want to
take one spaghetti out you have to pull
along its length and that takes a long
time and that's why these thickeners
these polymer thickeners are so
effective at
using the viscosity of a fluid